last year china went from being the
biggest bitcoin mining country in the
world to going completely dark
chinese officials set off what became
known as the great mining migration when
they issued a statement vowing to crack
down on bitcoin mining and trading since
then the bitcoin mining industry has
relocated expanded and in some places
seized on innovative ways to harness and
use energy
[Music]
before we jump into how the industry has
evolved let's quickly talk about bitcoin
mining it isn't just about making money
machines around the world work to guess
a complex series of numbers in order to
validate a block of bitcoin transactions
the miner whose computer cracks the code
first wins some bitcoin those blocks of
transactions are recorded on the
blockchain ledger a giant public record
of all bitcoin transactions forever and
ever by design this process occurs
roughly every 10 minutes and it helps
prevent fraudulent activity
okay so it might be hard to wrap your
head around but what you need to know is
that the machines help secure and
maintain the bitcoin network and as a
reward the owners of those machines can
make a lot of money so why did beijing
ban mining
all those machines need electricity
ideally cheap electricity to maximize
profits and china has a lot of that
especially from coal before last year's
ban china had attracted so many miners
that the country accounted for nearly
half of all the computing power
dedicated to bitcoin mining that's known
in the crypto world as the hash rate all
of that energy use ran counter to
china's climate goals plus bitcoin was
seen as a threat to china's own digital
currency and its capital controls so
beijing cracked down and miners packed
up in late june footage from crypto
mining farms in china started popping up
on doin the chinese version of tiktok
showing the machines being dismantled
and moved
it was actually an
amazing year to be a bitcoin miner in
the us because uh basically half you
know half of your competition went away
with the swipe of a pen this is nick
hanson the ceo of luxor technologies a
bitcoin mining services company and that
thing sitting next to him that's a
bitcoin mining machine we were getting
calls from people that had machines on
boats on the way to the us they were
basically calling up and saying i need
somewhere to plug these in miners
ultimately want to go somewhere with
access to cheap energy and a predictable
regulatory environment so texas and
other u.s states quickly became hot
spots the u.s which was already adding
capacity before china's ban took the
mining crown and ran with it accounting
for more than a third of the global hash
rate kazakhstan and russia also gained
mining market share so what has this
meant for the bitcoin network some
believe there was an interesting
security ripple while china's move
initially rattled the crypto community
and tanked the price of bitcoin it
addressed a concern that the chinese
government could potentially exert some
control over the cryptocurrency because
so much mining was being done within its
borders in the months following china's
ban el salvador adopted bitcoin as a
national currency the u.s approved the
first bitcoin futures based etf and
professional investors surged into
cryptocurrencies at record rates just
this month fort worth texas became the
first u.s city to mine bitcoin with
public resources and fidelity announced
it would allow retirement savers to put
bitcoin in their 401ks while these moves
haven't explicitly been tied to
beijing's ban some in the crypto
community believe that because mining is
no longer concentrated in china some
officials and investors have become more
comfortable with bitcoin china's
crackdown has also caused ripple effects
for the energy industry the bitcoin
mining council a forum comprised of some
of the biggest players in the mining
industry released data indicating that
some notable things have happened since
the first quarter of last year after
china's ban there was a steep drop in
energy usage that still hasn't climbed
back to where it was even though the
hash rate the global computing power
dedicated to mining has reached new
highs the process of mining bitcoin has
become more efficient more hashes for
less energy and the percentage of
electricity coming from sustainable
sources to do that mining has jumped to
58
in the u.s where environmental standards
are higher and investors care about
reducing carbon emissions companies have
invested in a wide range of power
projects miners are partnering with
nuclear power plants that have excess
carbon free energy they're ramping up
businesses that harness the energy from
flare gas and they're repurposing old
fossil fuel factories to power their
machines with clean energy some
proponents of bitcoin even argue that
the mining industry is incentivizing the
growth of renewable energy
infrastructure if the wind is blowing
and the sun is shining but people don't
immediately need all of that energy
that's being produced that energy
doesn't get saved anywhere it doesn't
get banked or stored for another time
but miners are finding ways to use and
monetize that excess energy now you can
actually use bitcoin and
use that energy that would have
otherwise been either wasted or
discarded and
use it to make money and then reinvest
into more solar power more solar panels
more wind etc still as the u.s mining
industry grows it continues to face
backlash for contributing to climate
change pushing some companies to sign a
crypto climate accord nick's company
luxor is one of those companies in new
york a top mining state there's now a
political battle to restrict mining and
environmentalists have called on bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies to lower
their energy use by abandoning the
current mining process known as the
proof-of-work method what do you say to
people who think
this proof-of-work method shouldn't
exist and you should just get rid of all
the computers proof-of-work is really
the only um method that we've seen uh
able to secure a trillion dollar network
anybody that's in bitcoin right now
thinks that bitcoin is still very much
in its infancy uh i would hate to uh
rock that boat uh especially when it's
so new changing the mining process would
require the approval of nearly all of
the miners and developers involved in
bitcoin something that's very unlikely
to happen at least anytime soon
while some investors and governments
around the world remain skeptical of
cryptocurrencies residents of turkey
have embraced them as their local
currency the turkish lira hovers at
record lows check out this video to
learn more about what's going on in
turkey thanks for watching and i'll see
you next time
you